tout a commencé en ce d'elad et le
naufrage du moskva ce navire amiral
russe dans la mer noire et puis juste
après et bien les rues sont attribués
aux ukrainiens aux forces ukrainienne de
le bombardement de deux villages
frontaliers russe et tout de suite cela
dit mi-août il a dit qu'il allait
intensifier les bombardements sur la
capitale russe alors jusqu'ici il y a eu
deux frappes notable la première avait
cheminé vie à une trentaine de
kilomètres au sud-ouest de kiev dès le
lendemain de la date de l'attaqué contre
contre le mot ce bâton naufrage
puisqu'il s'agissait il s'agissait là
d'une usine d'armement une usine qui
notamment fabriqué ces fameux missiles
neptune un que la russie qui tue si ce
que ce que selon la russie et bien
l'ukraine n'a pas utilisé pour pour
couler le navire amiral donc c'est
évidemment là une représailles directes
et puis hier matin à l'aube et c'est une
entrepôt de munitions qui a été frappée
à abu varie au nord de kiev d'autres
bâtiments cette information n'a pas été
confirmée
le dépôt de munitions n'a pas été
confirmée par les forces ukrainienne en
revanche ils ont confirmé qu'il y avait
eu des frappes que d'autres bâtiments
avaient également été touchés d'autres
infrastructures et on s'en est rendu
compte ici à kiev puisque est bien la
capitale ukrainienne a été victime suite
à ce bombardement de coupures
d'électricité ou encore d'eau et puis là
il y à quelques minutes pendant que nous
étions en train de nous installer nous
avons entendu deux bombes de
bombardement sur la capitale ukrainienne
pas très loin de nous et puis depuis eh
bien c'est le ballet incessant des
voitures de police et des ambulances on
ne sait pas encore ce qui s'est passé à
ce moment là on peut donc dire que
effectivement les frappes crise
s'intensifient sur la ville de kiev mais
la capitale ukrainienne n'est pas non
plus sous un déluge de feu en revanche
la situation est suffisamment
préoccupante pour que le maire de la
ville vitali klitschko est à nouveau
enjoint ses concitoyens à ne pas tout de
suite regagné la capitale à attendre un
petit peu avant de revenir à kiev
justement par peur de bombardements
massifs sur le centre de la ville par la
mairie sme